>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX
NEWS ALERT.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING
IN 2017, THE F.B.I. OPENED AN
INVESTIGATION IN TO WHETHER
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS SECRETLY A
RUSSIAN AGENT.
TRACE GALLAGHER IS FOLLOWING
THE REPORT FOR US TONIGHT.
TRACE?
>> YEAH, JUST CAME OUT, THE
"TIMES" IS REPORTING IN THE
DAYS PRESIDENT TRUMP FIRED
JAMES COMEY, THE DAYS AFTER AS
THE F.B.I. DIRECTOR, LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS BECAME
SO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S BEHAVIOR THEY
BEGAN INVESTIGATING WHETHER HE
HAD BEEN WORKING ON BEHALF OF
RUSSIA.
IN OTHER WORDS WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT'S ACTIONS
CONSTITUTED A THREAT TO
NATIONAL SECURITY.
AND WHETHER TRUMP UNWITTINGLY
HAD FALLEN UNDER MOSCOW'S
INFLUENCE.
NOW, THE REASONS GIVEN, THE
FIRST WAS A LETTER MR. TRUMP
WANTED TO SEND MR. COMEY ABOUT
HIS FIRING BUT NEVER DID.
IN WHICH HE MENTIONED THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
IN THE LETTER.
THE SECOND REASON BEING THAT
TROUBLED INVESTIGATORS WAS AN
MNBC NEWS INTERVIEW TWO DAYS
AFTER COMEY'S FIRING WHERE
MR. TRUMP APPEARED TO HAVE
SAID HE DISMISSED COMEY
BECAUSE OF THE RUSSIAN
INQUIRY.
THE INVESTIGATION ALSO
REPORTEDLY LOOKED IN THE
PUBLIC ALLEGATIONS OF WHETHER
FIRING COMEY AMOUNTED TO
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
THE REPORT SAYS THE F.B.I.
AGENTS HAD GROWN SUSPICIOUS OF
TRUMP'S TIES TO RUSSIA DURING
THAT 2016 CAMPAIGN.
BUT HELD OFF OPENING AN
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE OF THE
SENSITIVITY OF THE SITUATION.
OF COURSE, DAYS LATER, SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER TOOK
OVER THE INQUIRY.
AND NOW IT'S APPARENTLY PART
OF MUELLER'S BROADER
ASSESSMENT.
OF COURSE, NO EVIDENCE HAS
COME OUT PUBLICLY THAT
MR. TRUMP WAS SECRETLY IN
CONTACT OR TOOK DIRECTION FROM
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT IN ANY
WAY AND THERE IS NO WORD OF
SOURCING ON THE STORY.
WE SHOULD NOTE THAT RUDY
GIULIANIS A ISSUED A STATEMENT
SAYING, "THE FACT THAT IT GOES
BACK A YEAR AND A HALF AND
NOTHING CAME OF IT, THAT
SHOWED A BREACH OF NATIONAL
SECURITY MEANS THEY FOUND
NOTHING."
AND GIULIANI SID -- SAID THAT
A SHORT TIME AGO REGARDING THE
STORY.
WE'LL GET BREAKING NEWS AS IT
COMES IN.
MORE ON THIS FROM THE "NEW
YORK TIMES."
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SO IF YOU ARE KEEPING TRACK AT
HOME AND GET A PEN AND PAPER
BECAUSE THIS IS WORTH
REMEMBERING.
THIS IS WHY YOU SHOULD NEVER
CRITICIZE THE F.B.I.
YOU THINK IT'S YOUR BIRTHRIGHT
AS AN AMERICAN.
YOU CAN DO IT.
I WOULDN'T TRY IT, THOUGH.
THEY MIGHT OPEN AN
INVESTIGATION INTO YOU WITHOUT
YOUR KNOWLEDGE INTO SOMETHING
APPALLING.
MAYBE IT'S BEATING YOUR WIFE
OR DEALING FENTANYL TO KIDS OR
BETRAYING YOUR COUNTRY WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE DONE
IT.
BUT TWO YEARS LATER THEY CAN
LEAK THEY WERE INVESTIGATING
YOU FOR A CRIME THEY DIDN'T
COMMIT OR THEY FOUND NO
EVIDENCE YOU COMMITTED AND
THEY NEVER CHARGED YOU FOR IT.
THE WAY THE SYSTEM IS SUPPOSED